- Well, did you hear that?
TJ Hooker and CoStar William
Shatner is going to space?
Because I've actually met him
and worked with him and I love him.
- I've met and worked
with him well, obviously
- Yeah,
- I guess.
(audience laughs)
- Yes you did.
- I meet him once,
and first of all, I didn't know he was 90.
- I didn't either.
- Right?
- I Know
- Exactly my dad is 92 and while
I was doing this show,
I thought he was, you
know, I don't know, young.
(audience laughs)
I mean
- And in this industry,
you kind of know you forget
you forget age.
- Yes
- like I'm like, oh, I didn't realize
this person was like
20 years older than me.
I had no idea.
- Exactly!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
- I was just very intimidated by him
for a couple of years until I wasn't.
Until I found out he was 90.
(audience laughs)
- It's like, I'm cooler.
That's crazy that he's going to Space.
- Of course he would. Only he would.
- I know I think its really awesome.
- But at 90 going to, I mean,
just not worried, just
like, would you ever do it?
Would you ever go up?
- No!
I mean, me neither.
(audience laughs)
I really think it's cool,
but I'm kind of terrified.
- And I'm done.
- Well, if I didn't have kids,
I think I would maybe do it,
but I'm like worried
that I won't come back.
- Right.
- Or Something will happen.
- Yeah not good!